the 46th president of the united states
arrives at his new residence
and he kept his word and went
immediately to work
his first action in the oval office was
to sign a series of executive orders
striking at the heart of its
predecessors policy legacy
the mask in the oval another striking
departure
and the first order i'm going to be
signing here is
relates to uh covert
and it's requiring as i said all along
um where i have authority mandating mass
be warned
social distancing be kept on federal
property and interstate commerce etc
also among the orders the return of the
united states to the paris climate
accord
a reversal of the decision to leave the
world health organization
the lifting of the ban on travel from
some muslim majority countries and an
immediate cancellation of the state of
emergency
that donald trump proclaimed in order to
begin building a wall on the mexican
border
these are actions done at the stroke of
a pen but other fundamental changes such
as a new corona virus relief bill
and immigration reform will require the
cooperation
and participation of congress please
raise your right hand
and in the senate the new vice president
swore in three new
democrat senators in a chamber now split
50 50
it's the 49th vice president who will
have the casting vote
as a new senate majority leader takes
over
today the threat to our democracy from
the presidency itself
has ended but the challenges we face as
a nation
remain in the wake of violence and
division hatred and mistruth and from
the republican leader
warm words for joe biden who came to
this chamber as senator for delaware
49 years ago so i congratulate my friend
from delaware
look forward to working with him as our
new president
wherever possible and as it gets to work
the senate approves the first of the new
cabinet appointments
avril haynes is confirmed as director of
national intelligence
by 84 votes to 10 marking a bipartisan
start
to the new senate then the renewal of an
old tradition that had fallen into
disuse in recent months
the first of what are intended to be
daily briefings
by the new press secretary under this
guidance
from the president his objective and his
commitment
is to bring transparency and truth back
to government
uh to share the truth even when it's
hard to hear
and that's something that i hope to
deliver on in this role as well
president biden and the first lady
arrive at the lincoln memorial
for the final event of this inauguration
day
a day that took place in the shadow of a
pandemic
and the threat of political violence
but which ended in the celebration of
what the new president promises
is the beginning of a better and kinder
era
mike hanna al jazeera washington